那我开始我今天的分享那很高兴来跟大家做一些这样的分享也感谢大家百忙之中抽出加班的时间来听这样一个不是很主流的一个技术我先简单自我介绍一下我是Kill也是老司机记录中看到一个编辑那么熟悉我们周刊的同学可能会知道就是我们编辑在推荐文章的时候可能会在前面写名是谁的推荐但而以往那些没有写名字的就是我推的所以可能大家对我比较陌生但其实我跟周刊已经有走过四年多了
那其他也不多介绍了像我在哪里做什么事情那这个标题已经写写清楚了对吧那么OK我们直接进入正题首先我想给大家介绍一下就是说什么是排版我是去年7月份开始做小说阅读器这个项目的然后当然像阅读器里面的像ControllerVail工具栏或者说里面广告这些偏业务的东西大家可能也不是特别有兴趣因为确实技术难度也不高所以我今天主要会去讲阅读器里面的排版引擎的这个部分
那么这个可能是除了做过这一关的同学会比较了解之外其他同学会比较陌生不过没关系我们今天讲完大家就不陌生了首先我想先跟大家讲一下就是说当我们把一段文字交给urlabor也好或者是textreal也好或者是用calloutx去做也好那么系统是如何帮我们把文字排版上去的然后我们先看一个场讲OK 一个很简单的一段话那我们再看同样这一段话是不是看起来就很奇怪
对吧然后这时候其实我想问一下大家就是系统为什么没有系统正常都是按上面这段去排的为什么没有按下面这段排那么其实这里面涉及到一个知识点就是bassline这个图我相信大家很多同学应该都看过对吧我一往介绍color text的文章可能都会拿这个图列一下但是它并没有讲每个属性到底是做什么的而把一拍文字按照这种方式去排列就是依据其中的这一条bassline线去排的
这样的话它就会整个文字看起来更美观更合适一些而会像下面这个样子那我们再看一个场景这样一段话然后大家可以去其实跟我读一下就说排版那么是在固定的页面内将内容以适合的方式呈现这就是排版的定义同样我们再看还是这一段话我们可以再读一遍排版在固定的页面内将内容以适合的方式呈现这就是排版的定义
大家刚才如果读过两遍的话我不知道大家读两遍的时候有没有一些感受就是说这两句话其实文字是一模一样的但是读起来说连贯性等等会不会有一些不同如果我们看正常读书来讲我们是很少很少会见到像上面这样说把句号或者斗号单独挂在行手这种情况因为来讲当我视线扫到一行的末尾的时候如果发现这一行的末尾不是标点符号的时候那么我会下一次的觉得可能下一段的行手可能还会有文字这样才会
造成了閱讀起來更連貫所以說通常來講我們指示書排版也好包括我們數字、媒體、TST、小說這種都好那麼實際上我們在第二行的時候會把一個字拉下來然後這樣形成下面這種樣式就不會造成我們閱讀上一個突兀的狀態那麼這個也是說當我們把這段文字交給系統之後其實系統在排版層面幫我們做的一個排版細節上的事情
当然我举这两例子只是很简单的两个例子如果真实来讲武士这个排版细节是非常非常多的那么这时候大家我们也把排版定义刚才读了一遍就是在固定页面内将内容以适合的方式呈现这个适合其实就是对我们排版很多的策略去做成这样一个适合的方式然后给排版引擎也下个定义首先是
广义排版引擎广义排版引擎实际上是像整个外部有包括整个阅读器可以理解为是一个广义排版引擎它包含排版加预览面信任渲染的所有流程从内容的输入我解析以及根据预览布局并预用规则然后把内容排到合适的位置进行渲染和显示这样一整套的流程那么定于广义排版引擎而狭义排版引擎是指广义排版引擎中关于排版的这一部分内容也是整个排版引擎中最重要的一个模块
而我接下来主要会伪造了这个狭义排版引擎这一部分去讲然后同时也扩展一下排版类型来讲主流分为流氏和跨氏两种主流的类型流氏就是说左边这张图严格按照是从上到下从左到右一行我们去排吧那么我们平时愿到阅读的电子图说等等都是这种流氏的排吧
也就是说在不同的屏幕下屏幕框高下那么美航的文字数量也会有不同的变化而快适爬板就像右边这样它是按照严格的版面规划去做的排吧它是一个绝对座标每一块版面它就说是有一个绝对座标我们常见的像PDF这种那么其实是一个快适排吧它在不同的设备下它的显示效果是一致的而且不过通常来讲快适和流适是本身是可以相结合的这个就不多讲了我们本次主要讲的还是流适排吧
OK,我们说到,前面其实我们说到我们把一顿文字交给系统的时候你交给TexTV也好或者用KarlTex去自己绘制也好那么系统其实帮你做了很多排版策略那么其实我们也会想说我们为什么还要去从头去做排版这件事儿就是说很多系统已经帮你做好了事情我们还要再重新再做一遍那么这里其实是有一个背景的就是在我们启动新阅读系这个项目的时候呢想说IOS和安卓本身是各有一套阅读系的
IOS是基于Cortex的简单封装的它首先功能比较弱当然不是Cortex本身弱而是说我们基于它封装的能力很弱并且也只是TST这种格式那么安卓是基于一个开源框架就是FBradar这个框架如果做过安卓的熟悉同学可能知道它的开源部分15年之后就不再维护了然后我们是基于一个应该是13年还是12年的版本算下来可能到现在已经快10年了
所以说其实功能固然性已经很差包括问题也比较多然后更重要的是排版效果其实也不是很好尤其在中文排版上像我们前面讲的那个句号倒号之类不应该挂在航手那么其实是个标点的性则的排版规则那么它本身也不支持所以说那在我看来我们可以看一下我们下面这个图那么就有的许算我们看来我会有三大核心的问题首先就是说核心的功能缺失像文本复制这些竞匹一直都有的能力我们小说这边一直都没有
第二点就是说新的排版功能可能比较难实现例如我们假如要接入或需要接入以pub资源那么至少得在排版能量上支持像图文混排、表格、列表等等的排版能力那么这两点我觉得核心制约了我们的一个业务发展然后第二个就是说研发效率会偏低因为我们两套架构例如我想做花线选中这个功能那么
在安卓上我得实现一套在安卓上我也得实现一套而且他们的技术方案是不一致的那么如果你考虑投入产出笔这个问题的话让这个需求可能一直都迭代不上再者是说因为用了安卓那个三方库已经很久了嘛所以说历史一流的Bug也是比较多的这造成了一个开发功夫成本高最后也就是体验的问题那么松端各一套方案带来一个体验问题就是说说能排版的效果其实是长期得不到一个一致
再者是说性能也不是很好我们之前我们打开诱惑器的话光内随消耗器基本就在160兆以上而且卡段也比较多这是我们面对的当时整个面对的一个三大问题那么为了解决这三大问题呢实际上我们是希望从以下三个方面去做首先在语言上我们是希望采用世界家这样的一个跨平台的语言去做一个设计那么这样的话我们可以满足一套排版引擎去支撑多端的一个能力
第二是说从架构上来讲我们希望可以从解析排版渲染做一个全面的字眼因为这样的话我们后续很多功能的解带我们可以在技术上去做一个很好的支撑第三个就是说体验上我们也是希望可以通过提升排版能力以及排版效果去综合达到一个提升越多体验的这样的一个能力然后通过提升越多体验我们是希望可以以此带来一个用伤指标的一个增长这是我们整个项目的一个搭配性
OK,我们看一下我们整个的一个架构设计最上层也是容器层它也就是我们阅读器为由的部分像设置面板、华动容器、书签目录等等这些是属于偏业务的部分当时这块设计的时候我们其实也有一个诉求就是我们希望更多的逻辑由CaCa来承担因为这样可以最大程度保持业务逻辑的一致性那么利用像书签目录
然后章节管理然后广告的插拼逻辑等等这种非系统性的东西那么我们也是采用一个CIA加赖编写然后再往下就是我们整个排版引擎的核心的模块然后接下来我也会围绕这个模块去再去细讲那么整个排版引擎那会我们也是采用CIA加赖编写所以这样可以达到一个双端统一的目的
然后就语读器的话你像无论是iOS还是基于CoreTax也好还是安卓基于FBradar那排版部分对我们而言都相当于一个黑盒所以说扣展一个新的功能就还是比较难做到的当然不是说不能做到那么新语读器来讲我们前面提到我们这上面的三个模块Poster,Layout,Render模块我们全字眼的话那么在很多环节我们都可以进行一个干预然后再往下基础层的话因为我们也讲很多逻辑也改成涉下来编写嘛
这里主要是封装一些我们需要调度的一些基础能力包括现场包括文件读写等等这是我们整体的一个架构设计来看排版的部分的话这块也是我们整个架构设计里最核心的一块简单来讲的话就是上面这张图排版基础其实和瀏染期内核基础是有相似之处的然后在排版里面我们是引入了一套小样以及大样数据
小央数据和大央数据是我们在排版里面是用到的一个词那么实际上小央数据大家可以理解为对应的对应为当屋数那么大央数据大家可以理解为对应排版优点器里面的Render Tree这是我们最核心的两套数据小央数据主要是为了应对多种不同的文件格式像EPUB、TX等等我们可以统一解析成一套的小央数这样的话就满足了我们一套排版引擎支持多种图书类型的排版能力那么
然后通过排版的生成渲染需要的大用数据在排版文化我们会在里面应用各种不同的排版策略来应对不同的排版效果比如相对排版技术那么它可以解决列表签套公司等复杂的排版需求然后又比如说交手策略它可以实现标点净则这样的一个效果如果大家了解CoreTex可能会知道CoreTex里面有个CityRound这样一个东西它CityRound其实是包含了一组相同属性的元素
那么其实在处理文字的时候呢我们可以看这个选项数据也够里面我们有个CBOX然后以及大量数据结构了的下面有一个C-RenderLift那么它俩其实是跟可以理解的跟CityRound差不多的东西那么假如说一段文字有100个字那么我们是不会生成100个BOX的我们说我们会根据文字的语言种类属性等等把具有相同特性的一组文字当成一个BOX以及RenderLift
我們看下面這張圖可能就會更加理解我們是怎麼去構建我們的BOX的這段話總共有五行那我們先看一下第一行第一行總共有18個漢字三個標點而實際上我們是不會生成18個BOX或者三個額外的BOX的在這張圖來講我們只會生成8個BOX也就是這樣的我們會把標點當作一個BOX然後把一組相同屬性的文字作為一個BOX那麼
看到这个大家可能就知道我们在小样数据结构里面包括大样数据里的RenderLift我们是如何这个数据节点是如何构建的然后这两个大码左边这段就是我们很简单左边这段算是大家应该都能看到的大码很简单左边这段就是我们小样数据结构的一个积累然后右边这段右边这段大码是片段是我们大样数据结构的一个积累
然后去除ADD Child的这些功能的话代样数据结构里大家可能也看到了其实是包含了实际的做标信息的我们有set frame方法以及get frame方法那么这在小样数据里是没有的那么这也体现了其实代样数据是真正面对渲染的然后在小样数据和代样数据的设计上其实也会有一些额外的取舍那像代样数据上我们假如我们基于base render我们穿着一个text render的话那么我会把text render里面
具体的例如TextColor,Fundasize等等这些属性我们不挂上因为在我们看来,大量数据其实还是要更多的对外提供使用的对外提供使用的我们设计考量其实是偏向于意为或意理解这样一个设计考量的而在洗澡数据的结果里面,哪怕我们基于staff node去做一个text node
那我们也不会去挂具体的例如Tec,FoundSize,FoundColor这些属性而是我们会有哪些属性我们就ADD那些属性因为不是每段文字可能都有粗体都有鞋体都有颜色这样的一个特性的那么有几个属性我们就添加几个属性这话也是一个性能上的一个考量然后这方面我们前面已经讲过了说整个排版过程来讲其实是跟有软期排版基础是有一点点相似的那么想
大家可能其实一定会有一个问题就是说就这个问题为什么是内体物来做而不是外国物来做对然后这个我就回答一下这个问题因为我们前面提到过整个排版引程的最核心的三个文化就是数据解析排版还有渲染这三辆文化如果单看数据解析这一块的话那么无论是H5来做还是说内体物来做他们都应该放在有三家家来做因为这样性能的效率都是最高的只解析这一块
而我们做的排版引擎其实是可以理解为只针对特定数据的Webkit的一个轻量版本排版里面讲的小样大样就像我们前面提到的它其实就是对盎道姆翠和Render翠对吧而排版引擎就是专注于做书籍排版的策略这样自然而然就更加轻量一些而且H5做的话其实也会有一个明显的道门内存的问题像一本小说的话经常可能一张帖就几百页甚至上千页的情况这种也常有然后再者渲染上面的话
目前小说到排版型的话排版结果是直接吐出所有的元素的Frame作标那么到NATV这一层去汇制的时候是只需要按结果汇制就好了是比较直接的那么如果是H5汇制的话中间的调度层也是比较多的这是三个方向为什么会最终是NATV去做而不是直接调用外部标再讲一下我们在一些排版策略上的一些小的优化
前面我们介绍过我们排版引擎的几个重要的模块包括怎么样去提升一个排版能力那么接下来我去讲一讲我们在排版性能上做的一些小策略优化小说这我们当时老威多气实际上是有一个问题就是说大的图书文件它打开很慢网友的甚至是没有办法打开造成这个问题的核心原因是因为传统做法来讲我计算出一本书能排多少页我就得全排完那么假如说一本书是5000页
那么你5000个大量数据结构的话我们实际上算了一下虽然世界家的指針已经很小了它在64位下可能只有8币一个指針对吧但是如果5000页的大量数据结构的话我们算了一下也有三四十兆一个内存占用而对此其实我们是设计了一套解决方案我们是希望将排版过程拆分为出牌和系牌两步也就是下面这张图出牌就是说我只负责计算每页容纳多少的内容而不进行一个详细的排版
比如像左右对齐算法这种它其实不影响一页能有那多少内容但是它有很好时它是渲染所必须的过程但不是分业所必须所以在出牌中我们就不会加入这种策略所以分业的结果我们中间会额外产生一个新的数据结构就是配置Info这个数据结构配置Info这个数据结构它只存从每一页的开始结束的节点信息它只有一层的深度
占用内存是极低的也就是说我5000亿我们前面讲的5000亿我其实是没有生成5000个大样数据结构而是生成了5000个配置EFO数而这个数其实只有一层结构而当粤度器我们真正需要蓄然某一页的时候我们再通过这个配置EFO作为参数去调用精准排版策略去生成真正的大样数据结构所以说在接口设计上来讲我们就有了下面两个接口首先是分业接口
然后我们根据传来的一些分业的方式策略等等然后我们会返回给所有的sdf配置info这样一个list然后呢然后精台结构就是buildfdf结构我们会根据传入的具体的某一个配置info然后我会最后生成一个对应的渲染结构也就是lender配置这样一个数这样的话整体来讲我们在整个我们进入一本书的时候分业的过程中的话其实是
避免了一個其他的內存浪費的一個問題而且這樣的話我們分業的速度也會更快因為我們前面想過我們分業的過程中是不會加入很多像耗時但是不影響頁面能夠拿多少內容的一個排版策略這是我們在整個排版策略上做的一些小的一些要化點排版處理過程其實整個來講其實流程是非常簡單的
它就是便利一棵血羊树然后把节点上的所有内容按照一定的排版规则和策略去计算出在页面中的实际位置并且应用到大羊树的节点中整个处理流程其实很清晰但是也会有一些相对复杂的一些排版效果这也是我们需要考虑的一些其他的因素我举个例子大家可以看一下这个那么很多文章都会有这样一个效果尤其是指示书里面这里就是排版里面的手指下沉的一个效果
EPUB里面也是支持这样的功能的就是用普罗特元素去做但是处理这种效果的核心的方式其实是维护了我们在我们整个排版过程中我们维护了一个后链表就是挖洞链表如果发现这个后链表不围空的时候我们会去做一个计算然后去重新计算出当前的可排区域例如第一行文字因为I2已经占了前面一部分区域我们当
发现L面表不微空的时候我们会去重新计算一下第一旁可排的区域然后再重新在新计算的可排区域里面进行一个再次排版然后在现实排版中也会有一些额外的其他一些复杂的嵌套结构比如说像数学公式中分子分母等等以及像这种就是百度幼度的一个拼音的一个效果为了实现这个效果其实就应用到了我们之前刚才也顺便提到过一嘴的一个嵌套技术
现场排版技术也就是一个相对排版技术它的原理是我们在进入例如我排前这个字的时候前加前这个拼音的时候我会把前和它的拼音一起看作一个boss然后在这个boss之下我会再系排前的拼音以及前这个文字然后最后把前这个文字进行一个居中的处理然后再回到最终训练的时候我会再把整个的坐标系区做一个打平然后再让它们
回归到一个真实的做表节点这样的话就完成了一个整体的拼音的渲染其实就是一个相对排版的技术前面我们介绍过主要是一项排版过程等等主要还是围绕着便利小样的数据结构去做的而大样的数据结构的话我们目前除了渲染时候用到的其实也会有一些其他的常境、应用常境典型的像花线选中就是通过便利大应数据结构来做的
大家可以看一下这个图这个图的 us 比较简陋了因为这是我们排版内核的一个弹幕工程所以说 us 比较简陋的我们先看一下这个图如果我们要选中标题里面文句二这两个字的话那么如果要选这两个字我们需要知道哪些细心呢那么我们其实就是需要知道我们文句二这两个字的坐标位置而我们真实的大量数据结构里面这是我们闹过我们真实的大量数据结构里面我们会
存储每一个字的一个作标以及它的内容包括它的index等等那么当我们做花线选中这个设的时候其实就是根据上层传过来的Zester的一个作标我们去判断具体的某个文字是否落在这个作标内然后我们再结合前后作标去看看到底是用哪些文字去被选中所以说如果做到这个能力其实很简单那么其实也是基于我们知道所有文字在我们页面中的一个位置也就是这个图可以看一下其实
像点击上面的Metathase就会有这样的一个效果我们会在弹幕里面去做所有的文字的一个我们显示的具体的位置在哪里我们其实都是在排版结构里面都是知道的别说像发现行动其实就是我们便利每一段根据坐标去便利每一段然后找到具体的某一行再找到具体某一行中的某一个字在这个坐标内那么我们就会把这个字选中那么其实发现行动就是这么做的最后再来看一下关于排版体验上首先是说
体验一般都是一个偏主观的事那么如何衡量排版体验效果是否出色这个问题我觉得是有三方面首先是专业专业就是要用支持更多的排版效果因为当你打开一本书的时候你其他方面哪怕做得再好如果核心的内容丢失它都是不好的对此其实我们在排版家国上就像我们前面讲的我们可以用各种排版策略去满足这一点第二点就是说顺畅
因为阅读内的产品的用户的平均时长都是很长的我们首先要保障一个快速划动的流畅性常规的列表优化这里我们都可以用到不多介绍而像CPU内存等的优化也是可以减少这种长时间连续阅读下像手机发热发烫的现象这也有助于提高我们的一个阅读时长最后最后就是细节我觉得是对排版细节的一个惊喜打磨一个精力求精所以说我们也会从专业排版角度去看如何去把一些排版体验做得更出色
那么我简单举一些例子然后对于小说来讲就是保障用户连续越多一个连关性我觉得关键点是在于版面挥度的一个分布均匀那么什么叫做版面挥度的分布均匀呢就是排版的字语字字语标点以及标点标点等的空气分布更均匀以达到一个版面的挥度均衡的效果然后在设计场面上来讲挥度均衡的版面效果是整体感更强并且可以最大程度保障
用户在阅读中不会被突然的空白所打断也不会形成太紧密的压迫感从而达到一个整体提高一个阅读连贯性我们可以看一下下面这两个例子上面都是我们之前在旧的阅读器上的一个效果而下面是说我们应用了对应的排版策略达到了一个效果第一个左边那个第一个图呢我们是应用了一个行属标点体压的策略
然后会让航手的看起来会更对齐一些因为我们也知道像移动设备上手机上一行其实是没有几个文字的如果这样做的话会让我们整个版面看起来会更均衡一些这就是航手标单几压的一个排版策略然后第二个右边这个呢可以看到上面这个中间的两个全角符号那么他们看起来会整个给版面留下了一个比较大的一个空洞的一个效果这个在排版上我们也叫做空洞效应
然后这块我们也是应用对应的一个排版策略就是行内标定几压的一个排版策略我们整个把一个全角符号做了一个一半宽动的几压然后形成了下面这样的一个版面效果我们可以看下面这个版面效果整体来讲我们整体的绘度效果包括版面区域分布等等都会更好一些这会让我们整体长时间阅读下来会更连贯
这是我们在排版体验上做的一些小细节当然远远不止这些只是因为时间有限所以说举两个相对来讲比较容易理解的例子接下来给大家无外扩展一些其他的一些关于排版一些小知识左边这个图我相信大多数人应该都有看过所有介绍Cortex的文字里面文章里面都会有这个图但是前面也说过很多讲Cortex叫什么东西它其实没有讲每个属性到底是做什么用的
OK,我们先看第一个属性,也就是advanced-wise它其实是等于glyph-wise加上left-burry加left-burry那么整个advanced-wise其实就是当前字符的宽度但是它其实并不等于真正的字符的一个宽度为什么这么说呢?我们可以看字形我们可以看上面标题字形这两个字中间假如它俩都是80号字
我取第一个字我取80的宽度我排第一个字的时候然后第二次我还是取80的宽度我们可以看到它俩中间天然是形成了一点空隙的这也是整个字型互为我们预留的也就是LeftBrowing和LeftBrowing为我们预留的一些空间这样的话我们再排下一个字的时候就可以更美观一些而不会很紧迫把它们排在一起第二个是说Eston和Distant这两个属相
它是相对极限的上下高度值那么不同的字体可以有不同的一个相对的一值这个这两个属性其实我们平时倒是也不太会用它主要是应用于像某文等上下排版的语言它会用到这个值去做一个连接第三个额外讲一下是这上面没有的是一个current属性current属性这个大家可能听起来比较陌生current其实是一张表
它里面记录了不同字母组合的时候应该调整了一个额外的距离我们看一个例子下面这两个例子一个是VA 一个是VI如果我们正看的话可能看不出什么问题那么我们可以看一下这条线如果这条线过来的话我们会发现其实A排的时候没有在V这后面而是在V的稍微里面一点我们去排到A这个字符那么这个就是Curring的作用
柯润会告诉我们当v和a组合的时候我们a具体应该排在哪里而v和i排的时候我们就可以排得紧紧的排在v的后面而不用去做单独下的一个偏移这是我们柯润属性在真正排版的时候一个作用其实整个来讲关于排版包括自行库里面还有更多的一些信息是我们排版过程中真正需要关注的
那么时间有像我这里也不挨个去讲大家有兴趣的话也可以找一些参考资料或者说我们在群里也可以去交流这一块的知识ok那最后来讲其实是想给大家做一个思考那么这一块像这种阿拉伯文阿拉伯文是从右到左排列的那么大家可以想一想如果是排这种阿拉伯文的时候应该如何排因为很多像我了解很多做数字越多已经在做出海的业务那么假如说你做去做阿拉伯的
出海业务的时候那么面对这种阿拉伯文从右到左排的时候那么你的排版技术该如何做呢这个其实可以给大家去思考一下其实也不难有答案的同学可以在群里到时候也可以和我去交流一下OK那我今天的那个分享就到这里OK好的那个非常非常感谢那个泽磊精彩的分享就确实是一个比较小众的分享
我感觉我好像听了很多分享第一次听到这个方向的一些分享感觉然后看群里面有还有七猫的同学然后说里面你的两个策略他学到了还是挺有价值的